[APPLAUSE]
BETH NOVECK: Thank
you very much.
So I am the member of
the Obama tech team
who did not work for Google, one
of the few, as a rumor has it.
But many of you may be
familiar with the story that
has been that of technology's
impact on government,
both here in the UK, in the
US, and elsewhere, which
is the successes that we've
seen over the last few years
around opening the data
that government holds.
So I'm just curious, how many
people here have actually been
on data.gov or data.gov.uk?
Ah, not a bad number.
Done any hackathons, datathons,
any kind of mashing up?
Well, at least you've been
there, and you know what it is.
And so that already
is part of the success
story about how technology is
beginning to change government.
So this is, of course--
this is not of course.
This is a picture from one
of my favorite restaurants
in Chicago.
This is probably better
known to you than data.gov.
It's called Alinea.
Its the top rated
restaurant in Chicago.
And the reason I
show this to you
is not only because I love
food, but because Chicago
is one of those places
that has a great success
story around open data, right?
Typically the way a city
deals with food borne illness
is through sending out a couple
of inspectors into restaurants.
They go down a
list, you know, go
through the list of the whole
restaurants once a year, right?
And they inspect
them one at a time.
So what does Chicago do, right?
They look at the data,
the open data that
now exists about the
incidence of food
borne illness and restaurants.
And they develop an
algorithm to prioritize which
restaurants to inspect first.
Because Chicago, like London,
being a great food town,
of course, has
thousands of restaurants
but only a handful of inspectors
to have to do this major job.
And so they've been able
to dramatically reduce
the incidence of illness,
serious and otherwise,
by using data to improve
how government functions.
So this is just but one example
of some of the successes
that we've seen since Obama
on his first day in office,
and Cameron not too long
after his first day in office,
said, we're going to turn
around and open up the data
that government holds.
This was part of a
three-prong strategy
to change fundamentally
how government
works using technology, right?
We're going to make
it more transparent.
it more participatory.
And we're going to make
it more collaborative.
And that open data story
has led to a lot of success
and a lot of impacts.
We're just, of course,
at the beginning
of that revolution
in data driven
government and governing.
But we're seeing a lot of
ways in which data is helping
government to work
better, to become
more accountable, enabling
more businesses to get started.
Google uses a lot
of open government
data in its own businesses
to drive a lot of services
that you provide to consumers.
It enables consumers,
of course, thanks
to some of the
innovations that you
create, to make better choices
like which hospital to go
to based on the
comparative infection
rates at those hospitals--
again, something
I can get from looking on Google
but that's driven ultimately
by government data.
But the lesser
developed story is
what's happening in those other
two areas of participation
and collaboration.
So if the last five
years has really
have been about
beginning the revolution
in open data, the next five
years, I want to put to you,
is going to be about that shift
from data.gov to people.gov,
to using technology,
data driven technologies,
to enable us to do
for our country,
to participate in new ways, to
make our government smarter,
and to make it more effective.
And we can see whether
I can convince Will
that we can actually
do things better
than we can do them today.
And let me say as a
caveat in the outset,
and though I'm happy
to talk in the Q&A
about politics--
coming from the US,
there's plenty to
talk about right now.
But what I'm talking
to you about today
is what happens the
day after the election.
So after Bernie Sanders,
or Donald Trump,
or whoever it may be becomes
president in November,
and after you exit Europe,
or you don't exit Europe,
and Scotland leaves, or
it doesn't, or whatever
is going to happen
in the next year,
it has to do with
what happens the day
after these political
decisions are
made that allow us to deliver
health care, and education,
and take out the trash, and
solve problems of illness,
and pandemic, and global
warming, et cetera.
So technology is
beginning to help us to do
these things better, right?
We have for a long
time held the ideal
and known about the idea of
asking citizens for their input
into how we make decisions,
usually by asking people
for their opinion, right?
We poll people.
Well, how do you feel
about this policy?
Should we exit Europe or not?
Should Scotland leave or not?
And technology is helping us to
do that faster and more quickly
than we've done it before.
How many people
have actually signed
a petition on E-petitions?
Oh, quite a number.
How many people have written
a petition, posted a petition?
Any disgruntled folk out
there-- on either this site
or this site?
Let me see the hand.
What was the petition
that you signed,
for someone who signed one?
There was a lot of
hands that went.
I think there was one--
[LAUGHTER]
Nobody's willing, sorry.
I don't want to, you
know-- you're in the US,
of course, the two
most popular petitions,
you know what they were.
So the two most popular
petitions, yes, you know.
AUDIENCE: Death star?
BETH NOVECK: Yes,
build a Death Star.
The White House should
build a Death Star--
not the most popular,
the second most popular.
First most popular?
AUDIENCE: Deport Bieber?
BETH NOVECK: Deport Bieber
back to Canada, yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Very apropos with the
Grammy's this week.
So I'm not sure I've
convinced Will yet.
If I stop here, I
haven't convinced will
that we're making
government work any better
using technology if that's
the best that we can do.
What's interesting though
is the ways in which,
perhaps a little
less well known,
that we're beginning
to use technology
to actually get at not what
people feel about politics,
and policy, and government,
but that actually get
at what people know and can do.
So we're seeing lots of
instances of the ways
in which NGOs more so,
but government beginning,
are tapping into
what people can do.
I don't have a
slide up for it now.
But for this room,
I want to make
sure to point out to you that in
British Columbia, for example,
they've created something
called the BC Developers
Exchange, which is a way that
the government is reaching out
to engineers and
techies in the community
to get help with doing
technical projects
and lending their know-how.
In Sao Paulo, starting in
November, Brazil's largest
city, the government
said, we don't know enough
about tech and innovation.
And so instead of
our usual method
of sending civil servants to the
civil service training college,
we're going to ask people in
the community to teach us.
We're going to come to you and
say, want to teach courses?
Want to teach
government how to use R,
how to use Python, how to
scrape data, how to whatever
it may be?
You pick the topic.
You tell us what we should know.
And now they have 24,000
government officials
enrolled in courses
taught by techie citizens
to teach them to become
more tech literate.
A lot of these projects
are also not just
about kind of time and tasks,
but also about ideas, right?
So if I go on Madrid
website right now,
I can share my know-how
about how to create
Madrid's new transparency law.
I can go to Paris
and tell the mayor
where to put more
bathrooms in Paris
or what I think we
should do better there.
And we can contribute our
know-how as well as our views
about things.
So I got my start in
doing a lot of this work,
or the best known
project I've done,
before going to the White
House, was a project called Peer
to Patent.
It was designed to enable
volunteer technologists
and scientists out there in
industry and in universities
to volunteer 10
minutes of their time
to share advice and information
with a patent examiner.
Because a patent examiner,
at least in those days,
had about 15 hours to
do all the research
and do all the work of
examining the patents that
would get the next,
you know, 20 years
of monopoly rights over
the technology that goes
into this phone, for example.
Sorry, I'm not allowed to
show this phone, right?
That other phone-- wee, that's
why they're in lawsuits, right?
Because you only have
15 hours to do the work.
So why not reach out to the
people in this room and say,
who knows about this issue?
For the patent examiner,
it takes 15 hours.
For you, it probably
would take 15 minutes,
because it's the thing you
work on in your day job.
So fast forward
to five years ago,
2011, and the federal
government in the United States
builds on this idea to create
a website called challenge.gov.
So I've tested you
on the data.gov.
How many people have been on
or participated in a Challenge?
Whoa, for the record, no hands.
Am I correct?
Not a single hand.
So I would encourage
you to go on here.
They pay you enough at
Google, so you may not
need to win the multimillion
dollar prizes that
are on here for coming up
with an idea for how to remove
the salt from salt water
to improve agriculture
and farming in the
developing world.
You don't necessarily need
to earn the prize that
relates to how to use
technology to reduce the word
gap between the number of words
a rich child and a poor child
hears before he or
she is five years old.
But you could.
And it's a little
depressing that you don't
know about that opportunity.
Maybe food is your
thing, as it is for me.
You want to help the European
Food Safety Agency, which
after the controversy over
its rulings on GMO cereals--
in other words, saying they're
safe when a lot of people
feel that they're
not-- they're now
moving to look at how they can
crowdsource expertise instead
of making these
scientific decisions,
controversial scientific
decisions behind closed doors.
The challenge and
the problem, though,
that I would put
to you, the reason
that you haven't been on
challenge.gov and the reason
that government doesn't look
fundamentally different today
than it did 10 years
ago is a problem
that technology can
help us to solve.
And that is that the way
that we do participation,
the way that we do engagement,
co-creation, co-production,
whatever you want to call it is
through the open call, right?
Challenge.gov is,
hey, anyone out there
who has a good idea for removing
the salt from salt water
to improve farming?
And you don't know about it.
It's a tree falling in a forest,
because the government is
terrible at marketing, right?
It's terrible it's sales.
It is not very good at
doing what companies
know how to do so well, which
is to segment their audiences
and customers, right?
You know exactly when to
give me an ad for whatever it
is that you're
giving me an ad for.
Somebody, whoever out there is
responsible for all those ads
that I have to read, you give
me the ads that I want to read,
because you know
what I'm looking at.
And you know also that
because of my behavior
and my characteristics, I am
more likely to buy toothpaste
in the afternoon that
I am in the morning.
And you know that with
some scientific precision--
a very well-developed trend
in companies, not something
we do well within government.
Now I'm not talking about
heavy levels of data
driven surveillance here.
I'm talking about doing some
very lightweight curation
of the audiences who are out
there and better apprising them
of opportunities to participate.
Because right now it's too hard
to find the people who know.
It's too hard to connect
you to challenge.gov.
It's also very hard,
and we're not used to,
and we don't have the
cultural experience
that you know so well from going
on Stack Exchange and saying,
hey, anybody out there have
the answer to what line of code
is going to make my program run?
We don't know well how
to do that in government.
Because of course,
we have a tradition
and a culture of governing
behind closed doors.
If I say, in government, I
don't know, and I'm ignorant,
I'm in the Daily Mail tomorrow,
right-- as the ignorant person
who doesn't know.
But also, it's very hard
to formulate a question.
On Stack Exchange, it's
very easy to say, you know,
what is the particular
aperture for my camera
that I should use when
taking this picture?
But that's not
the same thing as,
how do I reduce the backlog
in veterans benefits claims?
How do I improve health
care, cure cancer?
The questions that
government tends to work on
do not lend themselves
very well to Q&A sites,
because they're
not very granular.
And we also really
have no experience
and no legal
framework for allowing
us to get agile expertise,
for getting answers
to questions quickly.
The typical way in which
government gets expertise
is through something like an
advisory committee, right?
10 people who sit on
a committee, they meet
face to face at Whitehall or in
Washington three times a year.
And they produce an
enormous PDF of 100 pages.
Before coming here,
I was just meeting
with an executive
from the NHS who
is responsible for quality
improvements who was telling me
about the audits that
the NHS conducts,
these fabulous data driven
research studies of performance
by hospitals across the UK.
But what's the biggest
problem they have?
It's the 100 page PDF.
How do you take the 100 page PDF
about hip fractures and stroke,
chock full of data, and
turn it into 10 things
that a hospital manager
needs to do or three things
that the public needs to know?
We're not very good at
agile in government.
So the question, and what
I want to sort of spend
my last few minutes
talking to you about,
is the strategies we
might use for moving
from a world of the open
call, crowdsourcing wisely--
excuse me, crowdsourcing
widely-- hello, anyone out
there-- to crowdsourcing
a little more widely,
where we do a small, small
job of curating people
who are out there who may be
able to supply the expertise
that we need.
So imagine that we're facing a
pandemic like the Zika virus.
And I will interrupt myself
and risk going over my timing
to tell you a quick
story about this, which
is I got a call last week by
a multi-national organization
asking me if I could recommend
a big data expert to help Brazil
with Zika, to which I just--
I almost fell off my chair.
You want me to pick
one person, one person,
who is going to be person
to solve this problem.
Why would you want one person
in this day and age when
I could have 100 people, 1,000
people, when I could have
a big data person, with
a public health person,
together with somebody who
knows the region, together--
you get the idea?
We have the ability to curate
and crowd source expertise
so that when we need
creative ideas, when
we need to find the
techies, and the doctors,
and the taxi drivers, and
the stay-at-home moms,
and the students, we
should be able to do
a better job of that.
We have the data that
does a much better job now
of telling us what people know
that makes that searchable
to companies, to NGOs,
and to governments in ways
that we can make use of.
So just to give you a
quick, concrete example
before I launch into
a few developments
in the public sector-- think
about something like HealthTap.
I don't know how popular
this is in the UK.
It's not even that
popular yet in the US.
But you get the simple
idea that it's a network--
excuse me-- of
doctors so that when
I, as the mother
of a small child,
have-- you know, my kid has
a sniffle, I can go on there
and find a doctor.
I can target that expertise and
get the know-how that I need.
And they're now using
this same network
to connect doctors in
the developed world
to crises in the
developing world.
This is because
ultimately, and what
we could spend a long
time talking about
is the ways in which
the internet is
changing how we define expertise
and how we make it searchable.
If I asked you how many people
in this room are on LinkedIn,
I'm pretty sure every single
hand would go up, right?
I'm going to ask
you also-- and I
am sure Google has a very well
developed knowledge management
system and HR databases
that will tell you
all about what peoples' skills
are and make them searchable.
And we have lots of that
relate to the credentials
that people have,
but more importantly,
also to the experience
that people have
or to the skills that
they have, right?
If I want to know if
a coder is any good,
I look at their GitHub repo.
I don't care what LinkedIn says
about where they got a degree.
Because 14% of the people at
Google don't have a degree,
right?
But it makes them better
coders, not worse coders,
as long as I know something
about their skills
and experience.
Some of you may
have interacted--
I don't know if--
Panos Ipeirotis, who
spends his summers
at Google and then
the rest of the year at
NYU at the Stern School
has done some amazing work on
quiz.us, a project supported
by Google, which is,
long story short,
essentially goes to prove
that people with passion
on a particular
topic-- in other words,
a patient who has a disease
and spends a lot of time
on the Web MD, turns out to
know a lot more about a topic
than a person with a credential.
And that's something that
he has set out to measure.
So we're seeing lots of ways
in which we can manifest
our expertise and lots of ways
in which we can actually make
it more searchable to people.
And by that, I'm referring
now to the technologies
of badges and digital badges.
So if I go to NYU
and I get a degree,
I now get a digital badge,
which I can put on LinkedIn,
or my website, et
cetera, that makes my
know how more
searchable to people,
allowing me to showcase
my experience, my skills,
my interests, my passions from
a variety of different places,
not just the place
I went to school,
but many different
indicia of the way
that I am developing my
know-how and expertise.
So let me close with
just a couple of examples
of the ways in
which we're starting
to see a move towards the
use of this technology
in the public sector
in the first place
to better tap into the
know how of civil servants
and public servants, but then
also to connect government
to citizens.
So I'd like-- and if it wasn't
clear from the title already,
I'd like to think about
this as doing for government
what we do for dating, right?
So if you don't like the
toothpaste and the customer
segmentation example, think
about Tinder as the example.
Dating websites are really
good at matching people,
matching us for marriage,
for dating, for a hook up,
whatever it may be-- it's
to connect people one
to another based
on their interests.
If we can take that
same idea and we
can take the same kinds of
underlying technologies,
we can do a better job
of actually greasing
the skids between
how institutions work
and how they get expertise.
[RINGTONE]
Sorry.
[CHUCKLE] Uh, that's
that other phone.
Health and Human
Services-- our ministry
of health in the
United States has
110,000 people who work there.
They have the responsibility
for the very hard task
of deciding on the safety
and efficacy of drugs
and medical devices
that go out into market.
They have to get
them out quickly
if businesses are
to thrive, but not
so quickly that they risk
killing people with devices
that are faulty.
So they've set up now
an expert network,
the kind of knowledge
management system that's
common to companies,
but to allow
them to tap into the
expertise or resources
that they have across the
department, across the agency,
something that had never
been able to do before.
And the hope is that that
will accelerate how they
get expertise and do their job.
It's more though than
just about getting
at credentials and diplomas,
like who has what degree
or what publications in health?
It's also about getting at
what that experience is.
So the World Bank just this year
has put its 27,000 employees
on an expert network.
And finding though
that they didn't
know how to use that to
translate into better
outcomes for solving
global poverty,
they also built a help desk.
So that now what
you do is you say,
I'm looking for somebody
who has experience
in setting up a well in
this part of Burkina Faso.
And the help desk will in
turn use the digital tools
to help you navigate
knowledge within the Bank
in order to allow them to
source the expertise that they
have internally that they
don't even know that they have.
The mayor's office
in New York City
does something similar
for finding people
who have the ability to speak
Albanian, or Serbo-Croation,
or whatever it may be at
the time that it's needed.
And we're starting
to see examples
of this kind of
technology coming
into public institutions.
Half the civil service
in Canada is now
connected on GC Connects.
But we're just at the beginning.
And you have calls both
in the United States
and in Britain, of course, for
using more technology to better
tap into the human capital that
we have in the civil service.
I don't have time today
to go into many more
of these examples.
I'll just end with one or two.
But if you are interested
in some of these,
or know about more, or want
to share more about what's
going on in the private
sector that people
in the public sector
could learn from,
we are trying to collect
some of these case studies
at a website called
Smarter State.
So let me just close by talking
about the ways in which we are
making the transition
from connecting
civil servants better, creating
better organizational learning
and better teams in
public institutions,
to looking at how this affects
our ability for institutions
to change how they
work with citizens.
There are lots of these
knowledge networks beginning
to creep up.
Vivo Web is connecting
over 200,000 academics.
And Agra Vivo is now creating
the spin-off for people
with agricultural expertise.
And we're seeing also
again some movement,
very early, towards looking
at how do we actually do this,
going beyond traditional
credentials and research
networking, you know, going
beyond what Google Scholar can
do in terms of telling me
what my publications are
and my citations, to
looking at how we tap
into the skills of
people in a community
so that we can get
engagement that isn't just
cerebral and credentialed,
but is also about boots
on the ground, getting people
to help and participate
in new ways.
Podemos, the upstart
political party in Spain,
has created something
called Banco de Talentos
to start to inventory the
skills and ability of the people
in their own movement,
in their own party,
in the hope that they can better
figure out ways to tap into it.
So the last example, and
probably the most powerful one,
and there is-- I've been using
this example for a while,
because there continues
to be none better.
But I think it's the
beginning of what's possible.
That is the ability
again to use technology
to target a single skill,
in this case, the ability
to perform CPR and
use a defibrillator.
So if you were in Mountain
View in California,
and before PulsePoint
came along,
and you had a heart
attack, these dots
represent the police,
and fire, and ambulance
who would come and save you in
the event you had an accident
or had a heart attack.
Come PulsePoint, open
data feeds from 999 or 911
in the United
States, geolocation
using my cell phone or any
cell phone, I might add,
that allows one to know where
I am vis a vis the victim.
And suddenly my coverage
in terms of first response
looks like this, right?
And for every second the victim
of a heart attack-- excuse me,
every minute the victim
of a heart attack
gets bystander CPR,
gets aid sooner,
doubles the chances of their
likelihood of survival.
1,400 communities now in the
United States use PulsePoint.
And as of four months
ago, the same service
called GoodSAM, a
service of the London Air
Ambulance out of St.
Mary's Hospital here,
provides the same
thing in London.
So if there's no other
message that you take away
from me today, it's
please sign up for this.
Please sign up and save a life.
Because there is a way now
for us to use technology
to target people's ability
and willingness to serve,
the supply of expertise
with the demand for it,
namely people who
can perform CPR,
who can use a defibrillator,
with a very real outcome,
which is to save a life.
So we should talk
in our discussion
about how do we get
from here to there?
There's a lot that we have to
do if we're to actually enable
these kinds of platforms,
if we're actually
to enable these
kinds of processes.
We've got to want to do
it, first and foremost.
And we have to overcome
a lot of legal hurdles.
I won't get into the minutiae
of US law or British law.
But suffice it to
say, we don't have
the legal frameworks that allow
us to do this very well yet.
We have to have the digital
badges and credentialing
systems that allow us
to actually do a better
job of finding expertise.
So I've given you a
bunch of examples,
but we're just at the beginning
of actually making searchable
what people know.
And companies like
Google have been
at the forefront, along with
foundations like Lumina, trying
to sponsor the creation of more
liquid badging systems, skill
based systems, digital
credentialing systems
so we can do that
kind of matching.
LinkedIn is involved in this
here in Manchester, et cetera.
So right?
This is your HR guy.
We don't care about
degrees anymore.
That means we need the
tools to better find out
what skills people have
and what they know.
Those same kinds
of platforms that
are getting developed
for industry,
that are getting developed
to better connect
job seekers to
jobs, can also help
us now to connect people
to opportunities to serve
and to govern better as we
build more of these credentials,
as we build more
of these networks,
and as we try more
to see what works.
So finally, Will, I don't
have all the answers.
I don't know what works.
I know that we need to do
a bunch of experiments.
We need to compare, you
know, whether the thing
that the Health and
Human Services is doing
to find experts to
examine medical devices
by targeted expertise works
better than the system
that the Environmental
Protection Agency is putting
in place to post projects
and say, hey, anyone
out there with these
skills within the agency--
does that self-selection
work better?
Does the targeting work better?
We're going to find
out as we do it more.
We're going to find out
as more people volunteer
to make themselves more
findable and more searchable
so that we can solve the
problems that we face.
Let me close by saying,
we have to do this.
This is not a nice-to-have.
This is not about the, oh,
democratic participation
would be nice, because
it builds legitimacy.
That's a good thing, right?
And if you are a
democratic theorist,
or a participatory
democrat, or just a citizen,
you really care
about the legitimacy
that comes from
citizen participation.
Maybe you had to read
your Habermas in school.
And you know how important
legitimacy building can be.
But I would argue it
is a false dichotomy
to suggest that participation
is simply about legitimacy,
and then the
bureaucrats over here,
the people behind
the closed doors,
they're the ones who
get the real work done.
And when you want to
effective outcomes,
you have to do that
behind closed doors.
We know better than that today.
We know that we
have to produce--
if we wanted innovation, we
have to produce it openly.
And if we want to deal with the
challenges of global warming,
and immigration, and Europe,
and all these hard problems
that we deal with in
the political realm,
we have to have a machinery of
government that does a better
job at stewarding
those conversations
and of bringing
in that expertise.
Credentialed know-how,
boots on the ground,
and people doing
tasks-- either way,
tech will help us over
the next five years
to build participation.gov,
not just data.gov.
So thank you very much.
I went on too long,
but I hope that you
will challenge me, disagree
with me, ask me, et cetera.
Eager to hear.
So how do we-- disagreement
particularly welcome.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This all sounds good except
that to make a difference,
it feels like you need to
get into government first
and then do something
in this direction.
So to that extent, how
do private institutions
or how do individuals
contribute to the government
or help the government
in implementing
this strategy or these things?
BETH NOVECK: So
what are the things
that private institutions
can do to help?
I think there are a number of--
there are a number of ways.
So first, one of the things
we've started to see--
and I'm talking about a lot
of tech-enabled, smaller
forms of participation.
But one of the ways we've
created the pathway for this
is now by building--
many governments
have created,
fellowship programs
where they're taking people who
are coming from industry who
will work for a year-- The
Presidential Innovation
Fellowship in Washington,
the Presidential Innovation
Fellowship in Mexico City.
Cities are copying this.
So there's lots of
ways in which people
can give of their time on
a more systematic basis
to get involved, and to help,
and to bring that know-how
to bear.
That's one way, but that's
a very major commitment
and only involves a
handful of people.
And that has its shortcomings.
The second way, I think, is
as companies and employees
of those companies
make their skills
and expertise more visible and
searchable-- in other words,
if we can persuade Google to
make some of what they collect
about you, with your
consent, of course, more
visible for civic purposes
and public purposes,
then we can do a better job
of tapping into those skills.
So Bill Gates, in his New
Year's letter this past year--
so Bill and Melinda Gates put
out a letter, their foundation
at the end of the year.
He said, we're going to
commit to spending the money
to build a global database
of citizens to fight poverty.
So presumably, that's going to
come also with the commitment,
I would like to think, of
making the know-how of Microsoft
employees more available
for public good and public
purposes, whether that's, again,
making those skills searchable,
giving people the time that
it takes to do those tasks.
I think that's going
to be a big way.
And then the third way is
also building the technology.
So at GovLab, in order to try
to inspire some of these ideas,
we've been tinkering
around with creating
some platforms to do this and
to show what might be possible.
But, you know, we're
not in a position
to build the tools, to
build that global database
of citizens that Gates wants
to get everybody networked
so that we can fight poverty.
If we want to
build networks that
cut across countries with
people with expertise
in given fields or the
networks of people who
can perform CPR or volunteer in
the event of a disaster, that's
going to take a lot of
private sector tech,
I think, to do and a
commitment and a willingness
to adapt the
platforms that we're
building for private purposes
to also use for public purposes.
So I think there's
a range of things
from giving of one's
time, sharing information,
to actually building
the platforms
and tech to enable other
people to participate.
Other comments, questions-- yes.
Oh, and if you wouldn't mind
also, sorry, saying who you are
would be very nice and
anything about yourself.
AUDIENCE: I'm Glen.
I contribute a lot to
open source software.
But I never done any
government projects.
And while I like the
idea of pulling people
from a common pool, the reason
I will not join the pool
is because there
is no open process.
And there is no shared
standard of collaboration.
So what I am saying is,
before we can do this,
at least on the techie
side, we need not
Tinder, but rather GitHub.
BETH NOVECK: Ah, so
I can commend you,
the work-- so there is, by the
way, a lot of GitHub activity
for government, including
GitHub's use for lawmaking.
There's also-- so
first of all, there
are-- let me take that
apart in a couple of ways.
There is obviously
in many places
now a move towards embracing
open source and open standards
in government in a way
that I didn't think
was possible a few years ago.
I literally got up in front
of an audience like this
when I started within
the White House,
and I said-- and I used
the analogy of open source
for government.
I talked about creating a
more open source government.
I was called into the
general counsel's office.
And I was grounded, essentially.
Do not-- whatever
you do, do not use
the word open source in public.
Quite literally, that's
what was said to me.
We have come a long way in
five years where now there
is a dramatic about face in
terms of embracing open source.
I was just asked to testify last
week before the New York City
Council, which is adopting
a bill-- I think it probably
passed-- which was a sort
of radical, only open source
unless you can avoid it move.
So first of all,
just to say that
from the perspective of--
there is a dramatically deeper
understanding of the
importance of open source
and open standards
in the public sector.
For all of these
processes, though, I
would like to think that
what I'm talking about
is essentially bringing
open standards to engagement
in some sense.
Right now we don't
have well understood
pathways or mechanisms
for how to participate.
And so your analogy,
if you want to call it
that-- I think you
mean it both literally
and as an analogy-- is
exactly what we need to do,
is to make it much
simpler, much easier
to create open
forums of engagement.
And that's exactly
what this is about.
Right now, the way
government gets
expertise for the most part is
a very, very closed process.
And we need to think
about how we open that up.
So I'm not sure if that was--
there's a probably deeper,
more detailed response to this.
But tell me if that-- if
I'm convincing you at all.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
That's a good response.
Just to give you
an example for what
worked in the tech
industry, before GitHub,
there was SourceForge.
BETH NOVECK: Yup.
AUDIENCE: And that worked
more on the pool model.
So there was no open process.
The collaboration was open.
But all of the development
happened behind closed doors.
And what GitHub brought on was
the openness of the process.
And with that gave us is, rather
than the talent pool model,
is that people would
contribute themselves.
They would nominate themselves
to specific projects.
Because the process
was open, so they
could get a feel of
what it was like to work
on a specific project
before committing themselves
to being an expert or being a
consultant on certain things.
BETH NOVECK: I think
that that's right.
And so as a
practical matter, you
are seeing a lot more
government tech projects which
are using GitHub as well
as government law making
projects using GitHub, so both
as a model and as a reality.
And if you're interested
in this topic,
there's a wonderful professor
at the University of Regina
in Canada who has written some
wonderful articles on GitHub
for government and studying
how one can actually,
literally, not as a metaphor use
GitHub to make government tech
work better, but also to
design government services,
and do lots of things.
So I think we're moving
towards more its open model
and processes.
And a lot of this
is about, look,
this is about creating many,
many more forms of engagement,
some of which may be
very small and granular,
10 minutes of your
time, and some of which
may be a much more significant
commitment backed by funding,
or a prize, et cetera.
So we just need more variety
in the opportunities.
So there's a hand all
the way in the back.
I don't know if we have to-- oh.
Thank you, mic runner.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm, I guess, a
computer scientist
is how I describe myself.
I'm not sure, by
the way, I accept
the thesis that the tech
industry is that successful
or a model for government.
But even supposing I did,
what about responsibility?
One of the key things
I want from government
and which the tech
industry is frequently
accused of not having is
a sense of responsibility
and mechanisms of
responsibility.
How do you see
that being grafted
on these quite open
platforms where, you know,
anyone can swarm in and write
something on Stack Overflow,
and maybe it doesn't work.
Or maybe it's self-serving.
BETH NOVECK: So let me say
that in the first place,
I am not suggesting--
well, I want
to-- let me-- there
are ways in which
and places in which we have
seen radical devolution of power
and authority downward to
citizens and much more bottom
up processes.
So take, for example,
participatory budgeting,
where small portions
of municipal budgets
in about 1,500 different
cities around the world
are handed to a
group of citizens,
in a fully transparent
deliberative process,
to decide how to spend
instead of the city
councilmen and politicians
who would usually
make that decision.
I am thinking here,
though, about making a move
towards more open
forms of engagement,
not necessarily by
abdicating or getting
rid of government in this case.
So in the Peer to Patent
project that we worked on,
we didn't get rid of
the patent examiner.
There was a very important
role for that person
to play as essentially the
arbiter of the legal standards.
Because a patent examiner--
patent examination
involves two pieces, a lot of
technical know-how and then
the ability to apply a legal
standard about the relevance
of that technical know-how to
the decision about the patent.
There was an ultimate
decision-maker
who remained at
the center and who
was the arbiter, essentially,
of the information
that was coming in.
So in many cases, this
is about maintaining
those pathways of
decision making and power
but doing a better job of
bringing evidence, and data,
and know-how into how
those decisions get made.
One more kind of answer
by way of analogy-- I
had a guy who worked
for me last year.
He was responsible for small
business policy in the White
House before he
came to work for me.
He was 24 years old when he
worked for me and 22 years old
when he worked in
the White House.
He had never owned
a small business.
Now he was very smart.
And he had an Ivy League
degree or two by that point.
But he had no know-how
and no experience and had,
you know, a couple
of days to formulate
what would be a national
policy affecting
large numbers of people.
That's how decision making
gets done today, right?
I don't know how many
people have seen-- what's
that great movie about--
with Peter Capaldi
about the British government?
AUDIENCE: "The Thick of It."
BETH NOVECK: What?
BETH NOVECK: "In the Thick
of It--" "The Thick of It"
was the TV show.
The movie-- "In the
Loop," "In the Loop."
So I don't know if you remember
the scene where Peter Capaldi
walks into the White House.
And this, like,
12-year-old kid comes in.
And he orders coffee from him.
And he explains, no, no, no, he
is the senior policy adviser.
That's very typical to
how government gets made.
Here they call them the SPAD.
We call them the
special assistant.
Whether you're 22
or 52, the ability
to have all the
knowledge that you
need to make the decisions
which government does
is very, very limited.
So the point is,
how do we open up
the decision making processes,
bring in more information,
and still maintain the pathways
of accountability that we have,
that government can be
quite good at doing?
So sorry, that's a long,
perhaps not-- I don't know.
You're looking quite skeptical.
You're looking skeptical.
And then what you should be
saying to me is, well then,
but doesn't that still-- if
you keep those same decision
making pathways, then
can't I simply ignore
all the evidence and just
make whatever decision I want?
Well, that's the problem
of politics, right?
But at least if we
have a paper trail,
at least if we have a
record, at least if we have
the evidence out there,
and the data available,
and the conflicting
opinions, you
will have to do a better job
of justifying your desire
to make a decision that flies
in the face of that evidence.
Right now, the 22-year-olds get
to make those decisions without
the benefit of that, so--
AUDIENCE: I was then imagining
the 22-year-old is sat there
with 10,000 submissions from
angry members of the public.
I'm wondering how we're
going to-- perhaps
we need more people
on the government side
in order to be able to deal
with this participatory decision
making.
BETH NOVECK: So
that's why we have
to move away from two things.
One is asking people how they
feel and the open call, right?
If I ask you how you
feel about small business
policy in the
United States, what
are you going to say to me?
Well, you're not going to say
anything, because you have
a job to do, and you're busy.
But the person I'm
going to hear from
is the person who
is nothing else
to do besides tell you what
a crap job you're doing,
essentially.
So I am the person who
has the misfortune,
if you want to call it that,
of coming into government
on the first days of the
Obama administration in 2008
and being so inclined, said,
we should have a WordPress blog
with comments.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
Well, I got my picture
in the "New York Times,"
not for the reason
that you would want to.
And I will just tell you
that the next day, they
put a sign up on my door--
when I came into work,
the sign on my door said
"Area 51, Director of--"
what was it-- "Director
of Intergalactic Affairs."
Because I was getting so
many nut jobs telling me
about Martians landing,
and President Obama's birth
certificate, and the
birth certificate
that was on Mars
with the Martians.
[LAUGHTER]
And no, they were not all from
Donald Trump at that time.
But the point is, if you just
do the open comment process,
that is what you will get.
You will not get
info that's helpful.
You'll get "Deport Justin
Bieber Back to Canada."
And though you may think
that is an important area
of national policy
making, I would
like to think that that
naked suggestion by itself
doesn't help us to
make better decisions.
If you want me to deport
Justin Bieber back to Canada,
then you should tell
me how to do it, right?
We need better expertise about
how to implement policy, not
just how to make that policy.
So the point is that
everywhere along the arc of how
a service gets delivered
or a problem gets
solved, starting
from just identifying
with the problems are, to coming
up with possible solutions
to those problems,
to deciding how
to implement those
solutions, those are
all opportunities for input.
But we know better.
And this is where I mean
about learning a bit from how
other people have done this.
It's not because I
think we should run--
unlike some people, I don't
think we should turn Washington
into Silicon Valley.
There are many people
who believe that.
But because we can do
a little bit better
a job of structuring how
we ask people, right?
Ask people a hard
question, and you will get
a hard answer is the wisdom.
Ask people to do
the heavy lifting.
Don't just tell me to deport
Justin Bieber back to Canada.
Don't just tell me to
build a Death Star.
Give me the blueprints,
and then I'll
build you a Death Star, right?
Otherwise you get
1,000 suggestions
like this and no more hours
in the day in which to do it.
But if you give
me the blueprints,
I'm much more likely-- and a
budget-- I'm much more likely--
[LAUGHTER]
--and the money,
then I'm much more
likely to build
you the Death Star.
So I'm being half facetious.
So let me-- I know you
want to-- there's rebuttal
coming in the back.
But let me see if there's
any more new commenters
or questions before we--
AUDIENCE: Well, I
have a question.
BETH NOVECK: --I let him
have at me in a second.
Because--
AUDIENCE: Big companies and big
charities are, by the nature,
international.
Governments and their users'
data, their citizens' data
have borders.
What's being done to bridge
the gap, and what can be done?
BETH NOVECK: So I think--
so favorite example here,
I was trying to
remember the name.
So it's a little town
in Texas, Manor, Texas.
It's a suburb of-- when I tell
you it's a suburb of Austin,
it sounds less glamor--
less cowboy like.
But just take my word for it.
This is a very
small town in Texas.
I've been there.
It has about 5,000
people who live there.
5,000 people-- that's not
a lot of room for creating
a public service, right?
So you had the guy who
became the deputy mayor.
He was about 24 years old.
He was also the CFO.
He was also this, and also
that, and also the other thing.
And he had some computer
savvy, whether it was
formal training or otherwise.
And so he had the good idea
that the best way to tackle
Manor's challenges, of which
there were many in a small town
with a high rate
of joblessness, was
to use a challenge platform
to look for good ideas
to solve particular problems.
And knowing that prizes often
create an incentive for people
to participate,
prizes were things
like if you solved problem
x in the school system,
you would win a cowboy hat.
If you dealt with
problem y, you would
get to ride along with
the Sheriff for a day--
and other things like that.
What happens?
He starts getting great
ideas for how to govern
better and differently.
But the ideas are
coming from Europe.
They're coming from China.
They're not coming from Texas.
And quite literally,
he said to me--
and I think we published
this somewhere-- the hardest
problem I had was how to
mail a cowboy hat to Beijing.
[LAUGHTER]
So I think you hit on
a very important point
that I had wanted to mention--
is that ultimately when
we start to recognize and
take seriously the distributed
expertise that we have and
to look at ways that we can
connect it better to
how institutions work,
we quickly realized that
citizens, number one,
are smart.
They can do more than just
vote once every year or once
every four years-- and
also that citizenship
is not geographic, right?
It does not need to be
limited to where you live.
If in fact your
expertise, your passion,
your know-how may be
around climate change,
or maybe it's around
dementia, the idea
that you might become part
of a global network of people
working on the
problem of dementia,
or diabetes, or climate change--
we can create the mechanisms
that I think allow us
to channel expertise
wherever it may belong
and wherever the need is.
So just to give you another
analogous example, talking
to the doctor today
about the 100 page PDFs.
I said, so what
happens when you get
that 100 page PDF with
all the data about stroke
across UK hospitals,
and you have
to turn that into a
set of recommendations
for what a hospital
should do differently?
I said, who writes
those recommendations?
He said, well, the
people who do the audit
of the data about stroke
in different hospitals.
I said, well, you know, if
this about how to better use
medical technology.
Or better conduct
an intake process,
or do something in
a hospital, do you
talk to people who
are in industry?
Do you talk to people who
do organizational behavior?
Do you talk to
computer scientists?
Do you talk to social and
behavioral psychologists,
who know things about nudges
and priming behavior, who
may have creative ideas for how
to solve the same challenges
better and differently?
Not to say that doctors
don't have really good ideas,
but they don't have
the only ideas.
And sometimes the best
solutions to a problem
come from very unlikely places.
So anyway, you've given
me a-- you've opened up--
you've let me drive a truck
through the hole you've
given me here in terms of my
answer to say that yes, this
takes the geography
out of citizenship
and allows us to
think more globally
about where we can
contribute our expertise
that it's most needed.
So apologies.
OK, see, I delayed
as long as possible.
But now you're back.
I'm afraid.
AUDIENCE: Rebuttal is boring.
This is a completely
different question.
[SIGH]
Are you concerned about the
question of incentivization?
So you talked about
prizes, for example--
BETH NOVECK: I'm sorry,
did you say centralization?
AUDIENCE: Incentivization.
BETH NOVECK: Oh,
incentivization.
AUDIENCE: So you talked
about prizes, for example.
BETH NOVECK: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That's one example.
But it does sound
like you want a higher
quality of contribution
than we've seen in the past.
And that's going to
take more effort.
Are you worried about who
will have the spare energy
or will have other motivations?
Are you concerned about how you
avoid capture by the lobbyist?
Or do you think there's so
much free expertise out there,
because there's so much
unemployment-- I mean,
so much spare time that
this won't be an issue?
AUDIENCE: Uh, so I'm
going to ask you back
about 20% time, the demise
of 20% time in a moment.
So be forewarned.
So first of all, you know,
this is-- the incentives
for engagement.
When we did the Peer to Patent
project-- Peer to Pay-tent,
as you would say--
and we asked people
why they were
participating-- so,
you know, this is anecdotal.
Because you're asking
people to self-report.
There are the people
who participated
in debunking a Microsoft
patent application because they
were open source.
Those were the days when
Microsoft was Microsoft.
Remember those days?
And so you hated Microsoft.
You were Richard Stallman.
You hated Microsoft.
You were open source fan.
So they would just
pile on anything
that said Microsoft on it.
So that was one
motivation-- hatred.
Competition,
another motivation--
you worked for IBM.
IBM told its employees, you can
on company time participate.
Because we want you to go and
pile on Microsoft's patent's
applications-- perfectly fine.
People did it though because
of professional distinction,
so the ability to
put on their resume
that they had participated
in examining patents.
And we gave them badges.
We said, if you contributed
prior art that helped a patent
examiner to make a
decision about a patent,
we gave you an award
called the Prior Artiste
Award and a t-shirt.
People will do a
lot for a t-shirt.
[LAUGHTER]
So people-- but right?
It's 10 minutes of your time.
It's 15 minutes for you.
It's a lot of time
for somebody else.
But it was a
professional recognition.
Why does Stack Exchange work?
I mean, why does
Stack Exchange work?
What do you get
on Stack Exchange?
AUDIENCE: So your
argument is empirically,
there is a sweet spot.
You're saying,
empirically, there's
a sweet spot where you get quite
a lot of bang on the government
side and the motivations to the
citizens are cheap as chips.
BETH NOVECK: Yeah.
I won't say that
on video, but yes.
[LAUGHTER]
They're going to put
this on-- they're
going to put this
on YouTube, man.
And then I'll get bleeped out.
Yes, because there's-- so
there's a lot of that spare,
you know, cognitive surplus, as
Clay Shirky likes to call it.
But also, in some
cases, the prizes
are monetary and financial.
So challenge.gov has
really solid cash prizes.
And, you know,
Nesta here in the UK
has sponsored the
anti-microbial resistance prize.
I think that's 1 million
pounds, or at least it's
a very large amount of money.
Google XPRIZE, right?
There's big dollars
involved sometimes
and some kinds of engagement.
But sometimes the level of
participation is very small.
Or the ability,
particularly for a person
at the start of their
career, a junior person,
a PhD, a post-doc, somebody who
has a lot of depth of knowledge
because they're very
immersed in a field,
and could really use the
kind of certification,
or the reward, or the
glory and helps them
with their professional
advancement.
Do you know how
many resumes I get
from people who write-- who
have their wiki Wikipedia
entries on their resumes, right,
as an indicator of service--
who put their Stack
Exchange score, right?
It allows you to
get a better job.
So there's lots of reasons.
And it also is social.
And why do people do GoodSAM
or do PulsePoint, right?
To save a life.
You don't do it
because you're going
to charge the person after
you use the defibrillator.
So that's a kind of
spare cycle that allows
you to do well by doing good.
And there's a lot of
that to go around.
But I don't mean to
suggest, in conclusion,
that these are all voluntaristic
opportunities, right?
It's also about changing how
we fund grants, and contracts,
and create more paid
opportunities for people
to engage as well.
So that's another piece of it.
But the incentives
are a spectrum.
AUDIENCE: What if
IBM were big tobacco?
That's a really nasty question.
I think you've sold me
on the low hanging fruit.
BETH NOVECK: What if--
AUDIENCE: But what if IBM
were big tobacco saying,
go and participate and help
derail the consultation?
BETH NOVECK: Their stock
prices are in a common place
right now, I think.
But we explain, what if
IBM were big tobacco?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Well, you were
saying IBM was happy for people
to take company time,
employees to take company
time to attack Microsoft.
What if the example
were big tobacco saying
that they were happy
to incentivize people
to participate in a health
consultation or a public policy
consultation?
BETH NOVECK: So this gets
back to where design matters.
So what we did not do in that
particular process was we
did not ask people how
they felt about the patent.
If I asked you how you felt
about a Microsoft patent,
you would have told me
what you thought about it.
And it would have not been--
we couldn't put that on YouTube
either.
What we had asked were
a highly structured set
of questions in which we said,
tell us exactly-- point us
exactly to the bibliographic
reference, chapter
and verse in the
scientific literature,
or in a piece of code.
And point us then to
the exact provision
in the patent application
to which this applies.
And show us why
this is relevant.
That sounds more
onerous than it was.
But we essentially just
had a structured form
that said, give us a
bibliographic reference.
It has to be between
this date and this date.
And tell us why it's
relevant to the patent.
And it's open.
And other people can
rate your submission.
It prevents a lot-- we
spent a fortune of money
on trying to prepare
for abuse and gaming.
And we had zero.
We had zero, because
of the transparency
and because of the structure.
It scared away a lot of people.
We didn't have millions
of people participating.
But we didn't need them.
What we needed were
five or 10 people
who knew, and had the
relevant information,
and could type it into a box.
So that's a very
specific example.
And patents, in that sense,
are low hanging fruit.
Because it's a very
structured process with a very
defined kind of
informational request.
But there are a lot of
places and opportunities
where government is
trying to figure out,
if they're going to
build the Death Star,
they need to know which
part to use for this
and which technology
to use for that.
I'm going to milk this
metaphor till it's dead.
It's not a good one.
But if I'm trying to
come up with 10-- so
if I have a data set on the
instance of hip fracture
in UK hospitals and
I want to turn that
into 10 recommendations
for how to avoid that,
I can ask you a set of three or
four questions that guide you
as to how I want to
hear back from you,
what the information is
that I want to get from you.
And therefore, I will
hopefully avoid your
telling me how you feel
about hip fractures, which
is useless.
So we can't end on
the note of useless.
So now I'm going to ask you
back a question before we close,
which is about 20%
time. [CHUCKLE] So
what's the current stance?
And what is the ability--
I'm just curious in terms
of people's voluntaristic, or
civic, or other engagement,
what that sort of looks
like for people in the room?
How engaged are you?
And what do you think Google
should do more of-- we
can turn off the microphone--
that would enable more
kinds of public engagement?
And I don't mean just
directly with institutions
of government, but
also in civic context,
anything that has
to do with solving
a public problem or a problem
in the public interest.
Am I allowed to
ask you a question?
All right, yeah.
You have the mic.
[CHUCKLE]
AUDIENCE: How many actually
have 20% projects about that?
BETH NOVECK: Say it again?
AUDIENCE: How many people
actually have 20% [INAUDIBLE]?
BETH NOVECK: Well, so I'm just
curious, in the first place,
about whether you still
have 20% projects?
I thought they were
sort of phasing out.
How many people
have 20% projects?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Or 120% projects now.
[LAUGHTER]
BETH NOVECK: I
see, I see, I see.
OK, all right.
I'm asking the
question the wrong way.
So do we want to know from
the people who have them
or the people who
don't have them?
Let's start just with somebody
who has a 120% percent project.
Just tell us for a
minute what it is
and what can be done better to
enable that kind of engagement.
Is anybody doing a kind
of public interest project
in their spare time,
I guess we'd call it?
Please.
AUDIENCE: I help in
educational program--
BETH NOVECK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --for
Polish teenagers girls
to encourage them to have an
interest in computer science.
Because apparently
in Poland, it's
a very male dominated field.
BETH NOVECK: [LAUGHTER]
Not only Poland, I think.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Actually, there
are countries where it's not,
or it's kind of equal.
BETH NOVECK: And so
what are you do-- what's
your-- what are you doing?
AUDIENCE: We basically try to--
we try to teach them coding.
BETH NOVECK: Oh, you're actually
doing teaching in training.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Kind of try to
show them that it can be fun.
It can be easy.
It can be doable by them.
Because there was a research.
There were a pilot
program last year.
And it shows actually the lack
of confidence in their skills.
So actually, we try
to improve on that.
BETH NOVECK: To boost
people's confidence-- well,
the President of the
United States last week
announced, you may have
heard, the computer science
for all, that every high school
student in the United States
is going to learn
computer science.
That's not going to happen--
British Columbia also announced
it the week before.
And I'm sure other places have
done so or are following suit.
That's not going to happen
out of the White House.
It's going to happen because
of you doing this and more
people doing this.
Without a much broader
distributed network
of people helping people,
we'll never achieve that goal.
So it's a really interesting.
It's a really, I
think, great example.
And can you-- do you want more
of these people to help you?
Or do you have to speak Polish?
AUDIENCE: I think
this is one limiting
thing, and to young people.
So they usually don't
speak English that well.
So it's limited for the
Polish speakers mostly.
BETH NOVECK: And so do you
have the ability to query--
can you go to Google
HR and say, give me
a list of all the
people who speak Polish
so I can ask them to help?
AUDIENCE: There is a group here.
And it was like open
question, whatever
you would participate in it.
They were just minor things.
And I volunteered.
Because that's not my idea.
It was someone else.
BETH NOVECK: That
was someone else's.
So was that self-selection,
post the project
and allow people to self-select,
which the right channels, works
very well.
And just from one person before
we close who is not-- Will,
are you doing a
20-- 120% project?
Well, this is one,
hosting me here.
But why not?
Or because you have
done your time?
AUDIENCE: Well,
there's a few things
that have to be in place.
You have to have
the time to do it.
the time that you
can commit in the
appropriate way to do it.
You have to the idea.
You have to have the
people that do it with.
I was working on one before.
But at the moment, I'm
not working on anything.
And what I was working on before
was just an internal tool, so--
BETH NOVECK: It was
an internal tool.
And is there something
that the company
could do more or differently
that would change your--
that would change this?
Or just an idea
has to come along.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, 20%
project or something
which are very
definitely on the side,
I think-- and for most
people, it would--
your focus is on
your primary duties.
If there was a specific
message from the company
that they wanted you
to do 20% projects,
if your performance reviews
included a strong aspect
of your 20% project,
for instance,
then I guess that would
encourage people to do it.
Otherwise, you're
incentivize to do your job
rather than do
your 20% projects.
BETH NOVECK: So I think that's
probably a good note to end on.
And it gets back to the
question about incentives
and the questions about what
companies can do more of.
And it's not just companies,
but also universities, right?
Because even for academics,
who you would think
would be sort of more
public-minded and what
not, they are evaluated
and reviewed every year.
And right, and their
budgets are contingent
upon your publications
and your teaching.
But public service is
not a part of that.
And it isn't typically
for most companies
the ways in which
people are measured.
So I think there is
an opportunity here,
not for imitation of
the private sector
by the public sector
or vice versa,
but rather for much greater
collaboration around sharing
data, around sharing know-how,
around sharing technology,
and ultimately about
sharing a common motivation
to commit to public service.
So sign up for GoodSAM.
Sign up for PulsePoint.
Save a life.
And thank you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]